Bugün size Denizli'nin kalınkoz Köyü ne
götürüp şimdi başlamak istiyorum
[Müzik]
a7a isteyen çıkan ne senin üstünde
çalmayan çıkabilirsiniz kadar parlak o
kadar zeki çocuklarınız var ki
ve simit televizyonda gördüm de çok
sevindim Çok gururlandım böyle bir evlat
yetiştirdiği için parmağımızı mama
evet hadi burada çok çarpıcı bir hikayem
var Aslında o da seni hikayesi annesinin
ve babaannesini gördüğünüz seveyim Sefa
öğretmen sınıf öğretmeni bizimle şöyle
bir şey paylaşmıştı Aslında Semih dedi
Normalde bunları daha düşük ve dikkat
seviyesi özellikle birşey odaklanma
sebep çok düşük Bir Çocuk bilim setleri
ile buluştuktan sonra çok enteresan bir
fark gözlemledim Semih nerede Bu da
aslında bu kadar dikkate dağınık olan
bir çocuk çevresindeki problemlere
inanılmaz derecede odaklanıp Onları
artık çözülebilir birer proje gözüyle
bakmaya başladım Her bir problemi bir
icat bir proje üretmeye başladı diye bu
Biz inanılmaz mı Belki ve daha sonra
senin not ortalaması bir artış göz
Aslında bu örnek Yani zemin örneği
onlarca çocukta binlerce çocuklar sadece
bir tanesi 2
bu seferberliğinde 200 bin tane çocuğa
dokunduk Semih gibi çok benzer Artık
diğer çocuklarda gözlemliyoruz ne oluyor
Çocuklar da asla her biri çevrelerinde
gördükleri problemleri bırak çözüm
geliştirmeye başlıyorlar ve çok
etkileyen lerden bir tanesi Van'da bir
köyde yaşayan bir çocuk virajı çok
keskin çok fazla trafik kazası oluyor
diye çirkin be notunun araba geliştirmiş
ciddi trafik kazalarını azaltabilirsiniz
ya da başka bir çocuk babası mangal
yaparken resim bir kısmını çevirmeyi
unuttuğu için sürekli babası etleri
yakıyor diye bir mangalmatik geliştirmiş
E bu ve bunun gibi hikâyeleri inanılmaz
derecede yani her gün duyuyoruz ve bizim
umudu zaten şeyler oluyor peki buna ne
Messi ne oluyor yani bu çocuklar nasıl
bunları yapabiliyorlar Aslında bu
çocuklar çok önemli bir imkan verdi
ettiler O da bizim seferberliği
kapsamında niye canlı parlak gençler
Türkiye'nin en dezavantajlı köylerine
bile Eğitim Bakanlığı yönlendirdiği ne
zaman taşınıyor
o en son teknoloji bilim setlerini
gösterir yumusak sahip olan çocuklar
artık bir imkanı elde ettiler ve bu
imkanı birlikte belli çözümler
geliştirmeye başladılar Yunus Emre'nin
şeyi vardır ya Çevik Bahri olmak gerekir
Denize dalmak gerekir Cevher çıkarmak
gerekiyor yegal gençlerde orada
öncesinde fiziksel olarak şimdi online
şekilde Anadolu'nun dört bir köşesindeki
bu cevherleri çıkarmak için çalışıyorlar
Aslında bunlar işte geleceğin Aziz
Sancar olacak çocuk Peki bu kadar etkili
sonuç veren proje nasıl hayata geçti Çok
kısa onu anlatayım bundan Dört yıl önce
biz Anadolu'da bilim seansları yapması
ve Aziz Sancar'ın en sonunda Profesör
Mehmet ben Çorlu'da Anadolu'yu geldik ve
beş gün üzerinde çocuklar film seansları
yapmaya başladı ve amacımız çocuklar
bilimi sevdirmek bugünün anlam ve önemi
ile çok uyumlu bir ses var Sesi olmamız
lazım yola çıktık vetrino dört yıl
önceden bugüne inanılmaz bir artı
şerbeti bugün biraz
bu Afrika'daki ulaşmaya başladım sadece
Türkiye'deki dünyanın bir noktaya geldim
basabilirsiniz içerisindeki modüllerle
ve elektronik sensörler Çocuklar kendi
robotlarını yapabiliyorlar bunları kodu
ediyorlar ve akıllara gelen farklı bir
icadı bu sebeplerle ortaya çıkabiliyor
Anadolu'daki herhangi bir ilde herhangi
bir seansta açık araba fiyatları
karşılaştırın ortak bir şey var mı beni
çok etkiliyor başlık Ya o özgüvensiz
hafif korkak öyle ilio modüllere gitmeye
çekilen çocuklar bir sürü 5 dakika
içerisinde yani elleriyle şu an dünyanın
konuştuğu o tanım arabayı
yapabileceklerinden İşte o zaman o
çocuklarda inanılmaz bir özgüven artmaya
başlıyor ve o seansın sonunda çıkarken
Artık kendinden emin daha dik Duran
çocuklar var ve o çocuk her şeyi
yapabileceğini düşünüyorum yani gelecek
en iyi girişimcisi olabilir En iyi icat
çıkaran olabilir bir özgüven artışını
görmek benim Bu proje olan inancımı hala
üreme bunu içeceğim
çok heyecanlandım geçtiğimiz haftalarda
bir makale denk geldim ve asla bizim bu
projemizin de az çok güzel bekliyoruz
ekonomik traş çetesini yazı bir fırsat
eşitliği ile ilgili yaptıkları
araştırmaya göre şunu söylüyor ve çocuk
yaşlarında Türk seviyesinde ailesine
çevresinde bir icat çıkaran çocuklar da
dost Einstein hepside kayıt için onları
da oynayacağım verilseydi onlarla
potansiyelin açığa çıkaracak
çıkaracağını söylüyor Aslı makale okudum
da fark ettim sadece bilim setleri değil
Sadece gidip rol model olmamız da önemli
değil Bu ikisi birleştirmeye geldi
gençleri bizim gönüllüsü gençlerin
elinde bilim setiyle gitmesinin ne kadar
önemli olduğunu farkettim Aslında rol
modellik çok önemli Siz kendi
üzerimizden düşünebilirsiniz Yani bir
rol modeliniz vardır bir olmadan
seçersiniz O ne yaparsa onu yapmak
isterseniz onu özlenirsin çocuklarda
öyle yani siz onlara rol model
Ya siz ne yaparsanız bunu yapmak
istiyorlar faydasız şeylerle
gittiğinizde çocuklar o faydasız
şeylerle yöneliyor Ama siz onları
elinizde bizimle gittiğinizde bizim
setiyle gittiğinizde çocuklar Sizin gibi
olmak istiyor benim ses ile uğraşmak
istiyor o yüzden bizim sloganımız
bilimle Sevindir Yani çocukları bilimle
sevmek bilimle sevindirmek onları
bilimle rol model olmak bundan çok
önemli ve baktığımızda burada kimlere
rol düşüyor okullara STK Lara
üniversiteler ama en önemlisi de biz
gençlere yok kendimi de o genç bize çok
önemli bir iş düşüyor çocuklara normal
olmakla ilgili Biz bugüne kadar
elimizden geldiğince bilim seferberliği
kampanyasıyla 500 okulda 200 bin tane
çocuğa ulaştık Ama artık çok da hani
güzel gelişmeler oluyor 23nisanda
başlattığımız kampanya giderek büyüyor
daha çok genç bize şunu sormaya başladı
biz nasıl bizim gönüllüsü alabiliriz biz
nasıl bu projeye dahil olabiliriz biz
nasıl çocuklara bile
bu başlayabiliriz A bu çok güzel bir
gelişme Çünkü az önce bir şey de çok
güzel destekleyeceğim yapabilecekleri
zıplama elbirliği güç birliğine çok daha
fazla çocuğa ulaşabiliriz O yüzden biz
Ondokuz Mayıs itibariyle Atatürk Sonuçta
gençlere emanet etmiştir diye O yüzden
biz gençler olarak bir hareket başladık
bizim gönüllüsü nokta oldu sayfası açtık
artık herkes bir bilim görürüz
olabiliyor bilim gönüllü olmak ne demek
asabilirim sesi edip bir dezavantajı
çocuğa vermek Mümkünse onunla seans
yapmak online fiziksel Onun için değilse
uçacağını Hediye etme bu şekilde rol
model olmak demektir O yüzden aslında az
önceki kayıp Einstein Lara kayıt diye
bakabiliriz ya da çok büyük bir
potansiyel orada bekliyor ve orada
duruyor diye bakabiliriz no potansiyeli
açığa çıkarmakla ilgili aranızda
heyecanlı olan Herkesi de bilim gönüllü
olmaya davet ediyorum www.bizimps.com
orada girip detayları inceleyebilirsiniz
Bu sadece ya gel yapabileceği bir şey
değil mi Ne yapmamız gereken
bir hedefimiz 2007'de 1 milyon çocuk
2023'te ise tüm dünyada 100 milyon ne
zaman karşı çocuğa ulaşmak şimdiden
bunun tohumları atmaya başladık
Facebook'ta görüşürüz Afrika'ya pusetler
nasıl getirebiliriz diye O yüzden sadece
Türkiye'de değil tüm dünyada ki
çocuklara hep birlikte ulaşabiliriz
hepimiz birer birim gönüllü olabiliriz
diyorum ilgilenen Herkesi de bizim
gönüllüsü nokta orada davet ediyoruz